sales managers today I want to talk to
you about a few things you're doing you
you are doing that's costing you
millions of dollars in commissions and
I'm gonna speak you for my own personal
experience on what I did in sales I'm in
Orlando right now at what is the
property code this is Kovac Arriba
Royale with top 1100 of our sales people
and we're sitting here and I wrote down
seven mistakes seven mistakes
sales managers making these are mistakes
that I've personally made that I'm gonna
share with you let me give you the first
one here this probably is above every
single one of them that I wrote on a
sheet of paper listen if you're in a
relationship okay anybody you're with if
you're constantly afraid of losing your
girl or losing your man you've already
lost them if you are constantly afraid
of losing your best salesperson or
losing your third best salesperson that
you have in your office or whatever that
person is you can't lead them anymore
you absolutely lost the idea of leading
these people biggest mistake I put out
number one is when a sales manager stops
leading his people because he became too
soft of wanting to make everybody happy
that is a very big problem if you can't
get over the fact that you're gonna lose
some salespeople at times you can't lead
them better now that's number one let me
give you number two kind of goes with
number one there are three different
types of sales managers and I'm gonna
explain it to in a way where hopefully
it'll make sense to you
you got the communistic sales manager
you got the socialist sales manager then
you have the capitalist sales manager
let me tell you the energy of each one
of them because the one thing you got a
judge an economic system on these two
the economic system on is what they
produce what types of people are they
producing in a a communistic environment
it's about everybody being treated
equally
which means imagine I'm a real estate
office I get ten leads if somebody wants
to buy a house I give one to him one to
him one to her one to her one to him
it's equally because everybody needs to
be treated equally so you're worse
closer who hasn't closed since the 70s
is getting the same amount of leads as
your best
that close it's 80% of times your
communistic sales leader socialistic
sales leader is about being partly fair
partly equal not fully either they're
just kind of like I don't want to ruffle
any feathers but I still want to make
sure my guy makes more money than the
other guy a capitalistic sales manager
does the following
who's our biggest closer keep feeding
them keep feeding them keep feeding them
keep feeding them keep feeding them it's
an environment where the top builders
top salespeople top performers are being
fed more than the others because this
environment produces a certain energy of
competition that the other two are not
gonna produce and if you're running a
sales office
if there are no bickering there's no
fights there's no arguments there's no
heated there's no friction there's no I
can't believe you won that I can't
believe this is it how dare you I'm
gonna be if there's none of that really
going on in a sales office where there's
competition going on you have a very
boring sales office I went to a company
a couple years ago there's a
multi-billion dollar company invited me
to speak to 60 for their executives VP
sales I went in there and I felt like I
was at one of these nothing wrong with
Deepak Chopra I felt like I was at a
Wayne Dyer or Deepak Chopra event where
everybody's holding each other's hands
and I love you so much we run a
harmonious sales environment because you
know we don't talk like that in this and
they kept asking we're trying to figure
out why our sales are down 18 months
straight well Mike you really need
another sign no one here is competing no
one is selling everyone is comfortable
you're not gonna grow business like this
what do you think it is in sports when
you're in a competitive environment you
have to fight for that starting lineup
you have to fight to still be the point
guard there's a guy that could
potentially take your how many times in
football do you see a quarterback could
lose their position to somebody else is
that a bad thing is that not harmonious
or is that threat making a leap
quarterback get better that's the whole
environment of a capitalistic
environment in sales that works if your
business it's flat you're either a
communistic sales manager or socialistic
sales manager you need to take a
personal inventory of how you're running
your business there let's go to number
three my favorite but it's not number
one this is my favorite peer pressure I
love peer pressure let me tell you
there's nothing
more I love in a sales office than peer
pressure nothing more there's nothing
more than Larry brought six sales in
today but Jackie brought seven there's
nothing more than Bobby made a hundred
and ninety three calls today and Larry
may 217 there's nothing more exciting in
the peer pressure it's Saturday night
Bobby wants to go home it's eight
o'clock he wants to go and kick it and
relax and do whatever everybody else is
doing
Jackie's sitting there saying you go
home first you go home first you go home
first
you go home first I'm staying a little
longer he leaves at 8:15 she leaves at
8:30 this is exciting
this is peer pressure she made him stay
two more hours when he was readily about
six o'clock
I love peer pressure a great sales
office with a lot of fire in it there's
a lot of positive peer pressure in it
and peer pressure is only in a sales
office where the sales manager the boss
the CEO whoever you call yourself give
yourself a title where that person
allows for peer pressure to be there and
I'm gonna go up to my point number four
which has to do with peer pressure
listen mistakes I ran harmonious I ran
communistic socialist I'm the guy that
ran I know all the suckers I've ran all
that that cost me a lot of money but I
just it right after two years I just
said I was 23 years old I made the
adjustment let me take this other part
here okay I love an honest office now
what do I mean by an honest office
because you know sales people we I've
been sales person for a long time or it
was like oh I made their 78 calls 99
calls it's only like 42 calls whatever
oh I did this much I'm gonna do this
it's always a little bit of that lies in
the sales business that takes place let
me tell you what I mean by honesty I
used to back in the days have every
problem come through me so we're in the
sales office every prom come through me
so we're not doing it sad no life one
day guy comes up to me and he says hey
Pat this other person you office said
this and I think it's unfair what they
did I said did you tell him anything
nicer why not well I just didn't want to
ask so I wanted to run your the Sales
Manager I said no you're unhappy with
that you need to call them out you want
me to call him out yes
go keep him honest oh my gosh I don't
know
and then I without did you yet know
about he's irritating me either calling
out and address him and keep him honest
or to get over it but I don't want to
hear about it anymore because I have
other things to do which one do you want
to do then they go address friction
friction friction bone problem solve
cannot they both gain respect for one
another it needs to be happening honest
environment reports keeps everybody
honest numbers keeps everybody honest
where I can see how many this I did here
but I'm doing an accountability and I
know what the numbers are those things
keeps everybody honest but I want an
environment where everybody can call
each other out everybody keeps everybody
honest numbers keeps everybody honest a
sales office that doesn't have that in
the reports are in public and you'll
generally I'll go to real estate offices
and I'll see that marker is a six-month
marker because I know old markers I know
it as a dying real estate office a dying
realist a not a top sales office marker
you go to it you just know it he just
wrote it today I like this office
because I smelled the damn marker that's
the sales office when I can smell the
marker because it's being updated daily
it fires me up to want to compete with
those numbers if I'm a sales guy coming
in if I'm one of your sales guys and if
you're watching as your sales manager
doesn't do this ask yourself do you get
fired up do you compete once the last
time you worked a little harder than the
other guy because there's no competition
for you you need it honesty number 5
number 5 number 5 number 5 is the 90/10
rule let me tell you what the 90/10 rule
is remember how initially I told you I
said stop being afraid of losing your
best salesperson because you can leave
them you officially lose the right to
lead the person so I want to lead you
when I leave you I want you understand
I'm okay if you decide to go to a
different place I'm gonna do my best to
lead you while you're with me here right
now sometimes coaches oh my gosh LeBron
is on my team
No if you're on my team I'm leading you
on team it get traded or go somewhere
else but I'm gonna lead you when you're
here and if you treat players like that
they stay forever instead of saying oh
my gosh woody leave he's leaving he's
going to another place
here's a 90/10 rule I would much rather
take 90 percent of my time and put it
into one guy and teach him what I know
and then after him
make sky and teach them what I know and
then the next gun teach you what I know
then take my ninety percent and put one
here ten percent here ten percent here
10 percent here 10 percent here 10
percent here at 10 percent so I'm not
building a killer every office needs to
kill Oh every team needs a killer every
league needs a killer every every
industry needs a killer
I want a killer in my office if you got
a killer in your office and you got 20
other agents and once killing everybody
that killer is firing up the other 19
agents is what it's doing
you need killers in your office the only
way you produce killers is by you
putting 90 percent of your time on one
killer then you move on to the next
killer then you give birth to killers
and when your office has a lot of
killers killers only keep killers that
means that office it's got so much peer
pressure in it that you cannot help but
being there and be a killer because if
you're not a killer in that office
you're getting killed being in that
office and that's the kind of office as
I like to leave that's why very few
salespeople wanted to be with me
initially calm down a little bit over
the years when we were hot listen you
better come perform it when we ran
offices okay now next let's get the next
one here in Senate I should do
incentives and my incentives will be in
multiple different ways well you know
I'm gonna go out there I'm gonna get
this thing here I'm gonna give everyone
one of these things to every guys now
I've given away shark teeth I've given
the most random thing I've got one time
went to Canada and about a dinosaur
tooth for 50 bucks and it was a coolest
thing that I gave away was a dinosaur
tooth who wants a dinosaur tooth but you
know I give that away I've done a lot of
different things but eventually
eventually this is what I realized if
I'm spending a thousand dollars on
incentives instead of doing one hundred
hundred hundred hundred hundred hundred
goes back to the 90/10 rule but this is
incentives do fifty percent of your
budget on one person then go if you're
doing three fifty thirty twenty but put
some of it if you're doing a thousand
dollars to twenty five percent of the
number one person then take the 750 and
put in everybody else make the number
one guy get a gift that's above and
everybody else what it is make that a
sexy gift make that a cool gift I mean
we ran a dubai contest one time the
number one guy I put on my borscht a lot
out Boresha lana was 3500 bucks a night
everybody else stayed at Utley
this was still 600 bucks a night but it
ain't 3500 bucks a night seven star
hotel
I remember that contest right if I'm
running a contest and I'm giving up a
Harley or if I'm giving up a Rolex or
the incentives at number one for my
killers have to be above everybody else
the way you incentivize your salespeople
will determine how many killers you give
birth to okay so don't take your money
and chop it up even amongst everybody
and then last one I'll tell you is this
let me tell what the last one is here's
what the last one is the last one is is
knowing that see if that's them because
somebody's at the door
the last one is knowing that in the
world of sales man I used to be so
impressed by Talent I used to be so
impressed by Talent watch these guys
just came in I'll give you a perfect
story with them Sheena Sheena man why
don't you just mom you guys this is not
even prepared when she comes to right
next to me comes to right next me we're
in the middle of an episode that you're
going to be sit right next to me we're
gonna be right in the middle of an
episode we got your guys well how you
doing baby because seeing you good
seeing you how are you good seeing you
so I'm on my last point with sales now
watch this here this wasn't plan by the
way they literally came in camera guy is
there as well point number seven here's
point number seven so I run regular
accountability calls over the years and
I think you guys will remember this part
here we started doing accountability
calls years ago 13 years ago 12 years
ago 10 years ago but in the last two
years I started running these
accountability calls it's a pretty loud
ok in the last two years I started
running these accountability calls and
we have sales people some are more
talented than others we have some sales
people that are overly talented when I
tell you overly talented I'm talking
overly talented and I as a newer Sales
Manager used to be very impressed with
people who were extremely talented to
disguise gonna kill it but it had
nothing to do with it let me tell you
what happened
I'd say nine months ago let me know if
you guys was 9/11 score eight months ago
all of a sudden rudolph on says he
started putting on believable
accountability numbers right like
because they started putting on that
they don't make your kind of money yet
but they started putting up
accountability numbers on how many calls
they were making on a week they started
saying 560 calls a week 39 appointments
a week right all these bigger activity
numbers and here's what it came down to
I would much rather take a Sheena and
math first year they made 200 secondly
to make a that I think there at 8:30
right now I don't know the exact number
with us $830,000 an income that they
take I would much rather take a person
I'm leading and building in sales that
is focused on the efforts the activity
then the talent if I can have somebody
that focuses on the efforts and the
activity that annihilates annihilates
all the talent anybody else may have in
the world of sales goal measure up your
accountability numbers with what
behaviors you want is it called is it
dropping off packets is it you know
presentations I don't know what your
world sales activity of behavior is
measure that in the movie Moneyball you
remember Moneyball right with the story
of the Red Sox and Oakland and all that
stuff and they brought brought this guy
named Billy Beane and Billy Beane said
in baseball the most important stat do
you remember what it was it's not
homerun
it's on-base percentage it's who cares
how many home runs a guy hits who cares
how many bases a guy gets how many times
what percentage of the time does this
guy end up on the base that's who we
want
so Oakland A's started bringing all
these guys that nobody knew about I mean
they weren't sitting home with nothing
but people were ending up on base you
know what happened Red Sox come I think
they offer him a massive contract what's
the number Paul 23 million what and he
turned it down any state he turned it
down but then what happened the guy took
the concept to Boston and they ended up
winning two World Series that guy went
to the Cubs in one really okay that's
the one part I don't know about so now
watch this here's a part no talent of
course you got some talent but on-base
percentage so sales managers don't be
don't be too impressed with your mostly
talented salespeople
impressed with the people that are
willing to do the activity that produces
results like the way these two guys have
been producing results but what can they
find you guys you can find you won money
money smart guy calm guy money smart guy
so let me well you want him to snap you
or you want him to go on your website
your website is fine okay snapchat
everywhere instagrams all anywhere you
goes money smart guy Facebook Twitter
this just kind of happened I don't want
to stop it since they're already we're
about to go have lunch here together but
so if you got any questions kind of
thoughts about this make sure you
comment on the bottom sales guys if you
watch this share this with your sales
manager and do it in a gentle way
because sometimes sales managers don't
like this message say hey boss what do
you think about this guy has to say do
you agree with them or not if your
environment changes with this it's gonna
make you a lot of money and your sales
manager is not gonna mind either because
he's also gonna make a lot of money so
we got questions comments thoughts
comment on the bottom if you haven't
stuff to the channel yet I don't have my
pillow with me but we'll use this please
be sure to subscribe to this channel and
click the alert button to be part of the
notification squad okay take care
everybody
[Music]